a theater owning koala a timid elephant
and overworked Pig a soulful gorilla a
punk-rock porcupine and an egotistical
Mouse are just some of the characters
you'll meet in the animated musical
movie sing yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and in this video I'm
going to be revealing behind-the-scenes
secrets and facts about the movie sing
including some cool Easter eggs just
before I start I've got a giveaway for
some awesome seeing merchandise all you
need to do for a chance to win is
subscribe and leave a comment on this
video about your favorite song character
or East Egg from the movie for details
about the prizes and bonus ways to enter
the giveaway check out the gleam link in
the video description below and if
you've not seen the movie yet just to
let you know there are spoilers ahead ok
now let's take a look at 17 fun facts
and easter eggs in the movie sing for
the soulful singing gorilla Johnny the
filmmakers channels Michael J Fox is
Marty McFly from Back to the Future but
that's just the start of sings hat tips
to the iconic mid eighties movie
remember when the theaters electricity
suddenly shuts down well Buster tries to
get the power back on by climbing out
onto the theaters facade while pulling
an electric cable from his building and
trying to connect it to a cable from the
building next door but like doc at the
end of Back to the Future
Buster's cable doesn't quite reach and
needs an extra tug Owen did you notice
the hands of the clock outside Buster's
theater are on 10 and 12 a shout out to
the scene in Back to the Future and in
sings finale when the punk rocking
porcupine Ash performs set it all free
she finishes with a final flourish on
her guitar as she knee slides across the
stage then she opens her eyes to find
the audience instant silence which is a
nod to Marty McFly's guitar-heavy nice
sliding performance of Johnny be good in
Back to the Future the inspiration
behind sing that it's characters comes
from a variety of places including Alan
Parker's 1991 hit musicals The
Commitments and for the character of
Gunter a sparkly spandex wearing pig
whose dance performances are super high
on energy the filmmakers took cues from
Brad Pitt's personal trainer character
in the Coen brothers comedy Burn After
Reading as for Rosita and overburdened
mother to 25 piglets sings
writer-director goths jennings based her
on his own wife who left her job as a
fashion designer to raise their four
children and like Rosita faced
self-doubt when she decided to route
to her former profession sink also
includes a couple of Easter eggs to
another of illuminations animated movies
The Secret Life of pets which is
especially nice because if you remember
a post of a seeing appeared on the back
of the bus in that movie okay first up
when sings bank robbing guerrilla gang
turns up they're wearing masks that look
just like the crazy bunny snowball who's
the leader of the flush pet gang in the
secret life of pets and in another hat
tip to that movie there's a crocodile
called Derek in both films in sing Derek
works at the casino frequented by Mike
the tiny Mouse with an enormous ego and
in the secret life of pets
Derek is a member of the flesh pets gang
during the five years it took to bring
the final film to life thing went
through various changes and there are a
number of rejected concepts for example
when the filmmakers first came up with
the idea of the theater owning koala
Buster moon he was much more of a
full-on con artists and he is in the
final movie however as they developed
the movie they realized that
overemphasizing buster swindling ways
and bad manners was making him way too
unlikable so they dialed down that
aspect of his character another
character who went through a big change
during the making of the movie was a
bullish business mogul who up until late
in the film's development was going to
be a big part of the story but in the
end the filmmakers decide that he wasn't
necessary to the plot so his character
had a major downgrade and now you can
only see him in one scene which is at
the bank where he gives a credit card to
the Sinatra singing mouse Mike who's
voiced by Seth MacFarlane as well as
writing and directing sing gas Jennings
also provides the voice of Buster's
assistant the elderly lizard miss
Crawley and keeping it in the family
Jennings four sons Oscar Leo Caspar and
ASA all pop up in the film voicing
piglets as does Asha blink off whose
voice you'll know best as Dracula's
grandson Denis in the animated movie
Hotel Transylvania - by the way did you
spot that the speaking voice of
theatrical diva Nana Nudelman is
provided by absolutely fabulous star
Jennifer Saunders who also voiced the
Queen of England and illuminations
minions movie but when she's singing
Nana owes her voice to dream girl star
Jennifer Hudson the grand Budapest hotel
director Wes Anderson also cameos as a
giraffe called Daniel who Busta axes are
the auditions because they can't hear
each other due to the difference in
their heights the voices of Despicable
Me director Chris Renault and Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world director Edgar
Wright also appear briefly in sing-sing
is absolutely jam-packed with music with
over 65 songs covering everything from
Lady Gaga and John Legend to Frank
Sinatra and the Beatles however one
particular track Elton John's I'm still
standing proved especially tough to get
permission to use taking six months to
get the go-ahead as at the time Elton
John's company rocket Pictures was
thinking of using it for their own
animated movie the Gnomeo and Juliet
sequel Sherlock gnomes the final thing
that sealed the deal and sings favor was
director Garth Jennings meeting with
David Furnish Elton John's husband and
Co chief at rocket pictures and sharing
him the scene where Terra neger son's
character Johnny belts out the song in
the movie
speaking of Taron Egerton although
seeing as his first full-on musical
experience on the big screen
Edgerton grew up singing and touring in
school choirs and while he was training
at London's prestigious Royal Academy of
Dramatic Art he won the Stephen Sondheim
Society student performer of the Year
award for his rendition of two musical
numbers including giants in the sky from
Sun Times into the woods however a sings
director had never heard a gitans vocals
before the Kingsmen secret service star
auditioned for the part of Johnny by
performing one of his favourite songs
Otis Redding's these arms of mine by the
way if you're wondering about those five
brightly dressed red pandas who pop up
singing and dancing several times during
the movie there is shout-out to the
music of the Japanese pop and fashion
phenomenon that is Carrie Pamyu Pamyu
now use your favorite character and sing
and what songs would you like to see in
a sing sequel let me know in the
comments below don't forget to subscribe
and comment for your chance to win some
cool sings merchandise for more details
and bonus ways to enter the giveaway
check out the gleam link in the video
description below you can watch more
videos like this by clicking or tapping
here and remember to turn on your
notifications to make sure you get all
my new videos as soon as they're ready
thanks for watching and see you next
time
EBI a movie lovers